hi welcome to the coding portion of less
than five your conference central
application is now in full swing you can
save conference and profile entities all
day and all night long if you want to
however every hit the datastore counts
against your applications daily quota
the good thing is that you can use
memcache to save your entity data to
reduce the hits to the data store in
this lesson you're going to find out
just how easy it is to save your
entity's data in memcache using
objectify in fact it's so easy that
you're going to do another exercise do
some underlying Java datastore API to
put values into memcache and to get them
back out we're going to create
announcements about conferences that are
nearly sold-out and store those
announcements in memcache there's no
need to save the announcements in the
datastore because they're so transient
in nature another thing you're going to
do is use task queues so that your
application can do work in the
background you're going to use task
queues to send confirmation email
anytime anybody creates a new conference
and to wrap it all up we'll set up a
cron job to periodically check for
conferences that are nearly sold-out and
update the announcement in memcache
let's get to it